lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
descubrir la masa de carbonato de calcio
que necesitamos para que reaccione
completamente con el ácido clorhídrico y
lo que nos dice este problema es que
tenemos 25 mililitros de 0.750 molar de
ácido clorhídrico lo que hay que
recordar es que cuando tenemos una
cantidad molar el molar nos dice moles
por litro entonces nos está diciendo
puntos 750 moles por litro y antes que
cualquier cosa antes de hacer cualquier
estudio de este que o métrico lo que
tenemos que hacer es verificar que está
balanceada la ecuación muy bien entonces
vamos a empezar primero con el calcio
del lado de los reactivos sólo tenemos
un calcio mientras que del lado de los
productos también sólo tenemos un calcio
muy bien vamos a ver qué más tenemos del
lado de los reactivos tenemos un carbono
este es cloro verdad así que sólo
tenemos un carbono y del lado de los
productos sólo tenemos
un carbono muy bien vamos a ver ahora
del lado de los reactivos tenemos 3
oxígenos y nada más mientras que del
lado de los productos aquí tenemos uno y
aquí tenemos dos lo cual está muy bien
porque sigue estando balanceado ahora
bien para él para los hidrógenos aquí
tenemos uno pero aquí tenemos dos
hidrógenos así que si nosotros ponemos
un 2 aquí en realidad ya están
balanceados los hidrógenos y sólo nos
quedaría balancear los cloro es verdad
por supuesto
no habíamos balanceado antes los cloro
si no este 2 hubiera hecho que todo todo
el análisis se arruinar así que hasta
este momento tenemos 22 átomos de cloro
y aquí tenemos otra vez dos átomos de
cloro así que hasta este momento la
ecuación ya está completamente
balanceado ahora bien este problema es
diferente a todos los que hemos hecho
anteriormente porque ahora yo les doy la
masa de ácido clorhídrico o mango bueno
les doy el total de la solución y su
concentra
lo que tenemos que hacer es lo siguiente
hallar la cantidad de moles que tenemos
de ácido clorhídrico y luego sabemos que
por cada 2 moles de ácido clorhídrico
reacciona un molde de carbonato de
calcio finalmente lo que vamos a tener
que hacer es hallar la masa de carbonato
de calcio muy bien entonces vamos a
empezar tenemos 25 mililitros esto es lo
que nos dan 25 mililitros de 0.750 molar
de ácido clorhídrico muy bien entonces
lo que sí sabemos es que cuando tenemos
unidades molar
esto es lo mismo que moles por litro y
nosotros aquí tenemos mililitros así que
primero tenemos que convertir los
mililitros a litros y eso simplemente lo
podemos poner como que por cada litro
tenemos
mililitros muy bien y haciendo este
producto podemos cancelar los mililitros
y quedarnos sólo con litros después
vamos a multiplicar por otra unidad
porque nosotros queremos moles queremos
saber la cantidad de moles que
necesitamos de de ácido clorhídrico
verdad primero queremos saber cuántos
moles de ácido clorhídrico necesitamos
para después determinar los de carbonato
de calcio y lo que sabemos es que
tenemos 700 no más bien 0.750 0.750
moles de ácido clorhídrico ok por cada
litro por cada litro de
0.750 molar de ácido ácido clorhídrico
muy bien ok entonces que fue lo que
hicimos primero cannes vamos a convertir
los mililitros a litros porque a estos
mililitros se cancelan con estos y nos
van a quedar algo en términos de litros
de 0.750 molar de ha sido así dijo
clorhídrico y eso se va a cancelar con
estas unidades de abajo y sólo nos
quedan moles de ácido clorhídrico
entonces qué es lo que nos queda al
final entonces esto se cancelaría con
esto de acá abajo y solo nos van a
quedar moles de ácido clorhídrico que
fue lo que nos quedó nos quedó 25 por 1
por punto 750
entonces multiplicamos por 0.750 y
dividimos entre 1000 que es lo único
entre lo que estamos dividiendo y las
unidades que nos restan son moles de
ácido clorhídrico entonces esto
necesitamos evaluarlo con la calculadora
así que sacamos la calculadora y hacemos
este producto tenemos 25 x 0.750 eso nos
da 18 puntos 75 y luego si dividimos
entre 1000 eso nos da 0.018 75 vamos a
quedarnos con 0.01 8 y redondeamos aquí
con 8 entonces estos son 0.01 88 moles
de ácido clorhídrico muy bien ahora bien
lo que nosotros sabemos es que por cada
dos moles de ácido clorhídrico se
requieren 1 de carbonato de calcio
entonces eso lo podemos poner de la
siguiente forma podemos multiplicar x
sabemos que por cada dos moles de ácido
clorhídrico se requieren vamos a ponerlo
con ese mismo color se requiere un molde
de carbonato de calcio vamos a ponerle
requeridos sale entonces estas unidades
se cancelan y nos quedan moles de
carbonato de calcio requeridos que es lo
que nos queda dividir
0.0 188 entre 2 que entonces aquí ya
teníamos esa cantidad si lo dividimos
entre 2 nos da 0.009 375 vamos a
redondear lo como 0.009 38
muy bien entonces lo anotamos vamos a
tener 0.009 38 si no mal recuerdo
y ahí está estos son moles moles de
carbonato de calcio requeridos vamos a
ponerle requeridos ok y ahora lo que nos
preguntan es cuántos gramos de esta
sustancia necesitamos para poder llevar
a cabo esta reacción así que hay que
convertir los moles a gramos y eso ya lo
hemos hecho muchas veces primero
necesitamos determinar cuál es la masa
molar o la masa de cada molécula del
carbonato de calcio y estos son bueno el
calcio tú lo puedes buscar en una tabla
periódica y ésta tiene una masa de 40
el carbono como ya lo hemos visto muchas
veces tiene una masa de 12 y tenemos 3
oxígenos entonces tenemos 3 veces 16
verdad entonces al final nos quedan 40
más 12 más 3 por 16 que son 48 48 y 40
son 88 y si sumamos 12 esto nos da
son 100 entonces tenemos por cada mol
dejen hacerlo con verde
con verde tenemos por cada mol de
carbonato de calcio
100 gramos de carbonato de calcio muy
bien entonces
oops lo puse al revés lo puse al revés
es verdad queremos cancelar los moles
así que tenemos 100 gramos de carbonato
de calcio por cada mol de carbonato de
calcio
entonces ponerlo de esta forma nos ayuda
a que los moles se cancelan y solo nos
quedamos con los gramos de carbonato de
calcio y este número si lo multiplicamos
por 100 como ya sabrán solo hay que
recorrer el punto decimal dos unidades y
eso nos da cero punto y el punto se
recorre dos unidades nos da cero punto
938 gramos de carbonato de calcio espero
te hayas divertido con este ejemplo